[Music]
when we were growing up christian and i
lived behind a family called the
chandlers
and uh we played with them a lot they
were really fun
family and in fact they were notably to
us they were the first family to get
cable in the neighborhood do you
remember that so they had they had hbo
way before anybody else definitely way
before we did fun family fun family my
fifth grade teacher was mrs chandler i
didn't know that uh todd the oldest
brother
will as of tomorrow be watching my
turtles he'll be turtle sitting for me
it's very very kind of him i thanked him
privately but i thought why not do it
publicly too in case he's listening so
anyway thanks todd and and thanks todd
especially because that means i don't
have to watch them that's true well
you're also going away for part of the
time that's true and uh and i also know
that todd uh had a turtle growing up
another reason why i uh i like that
house because he had for like years i
think he had a mud turtle it had a it
had a nice like name too i like when
pets have like human names like nancy or
montgomery
yeah it's a little cutie yeah i'm more
like like
steve or
dale you know uh i disagree my first
turtle uh boxster was named victor i
always liked that but anyway um he had i
know that he's able to take him he's
like and i think he's kind of excited
about it so
thanks todd and thank you for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you are listening to life is short i'm
your host turtleness host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my always
turtle-less brother not always well
that's true what if you had kids one day
and they wanted a turtle one turtle is
pretty different than eight turtles yeah
especially like the little guys because
they're ladies sorry they're females
they're getting they're growing a lot
especially the snap turtles i know i
watch them for a few weeks while you're
gone and uh
i it's a lot but yeah i i like them
they're cute i don't know if i've spoken
publicly about it well i guess on
instagram i put it on instagram i found
these there was a turtle that laid eggs
in our yard and um they hadn't hatched
on time so i dug a little bit and i
found that they were struggling to get
out of the nest so
i
saved them
they were hatched on my birthday as a
matter of fact september 6th
of last year and uh there were six of
them uh-huh and then so we named them
this september 6th
that's right and then a neighbor found
two
little baby snapping turtles that had
just been born and i was getting colder
and i was afraid you know so i have
these eight turtles that now need a
foster family and so
so really grateful to todd for doing
that no offense to your turtles or to
you you say they don't give back they
don't give a whole lot back yeah yeah
they're cute they're fun to look at and
they're they're cute they're not
affectionate watch them eat they're
certainly not affectionate no no you
just do a lot of work and a lot of
stinky work yeah it can smell in fact
for what well i'll tell you for what in
a couple years
the lake where we live is going to be a
little bit more repopulated because i'm
going to set them free this spring that
is cool and that's the by far the best
part
of them yeah i'm looking for and you
know turtles the chance that seeing them
plentiful and large throughout the lake
because i when i was a kid i used to see
them all over that lake we used to go up
there when we were kids and um and over
the years we talked to our guests today
about it who is this guest okay i know
uh because our guest today knows a lot
about turtles and all animals and
conservation we get i was so excited to
do this episode and um
i'm excited to see i'm so excited to say
who it is what is his name but i'm
stalling
his name is jeff corwin jeff is one of
the leading uh public figures in the in
the world of uh animal
oh that was terrible wow jeff corwin is
one of america's greatest
conservationists okay uh biologists
naturalists there you go he's hosted a
number of uh nature shows starting in
the mid 90s when we were kids um
his first show was going wild with jeff
corwin on the disney channel and he
hosted the jeff corwin experience animal
planet uh ocean treks is a great show
hey he's hosted a lot of shows and he's
one of our
great biologists
wow for the win for the corwin
um well done yeah uh and i think we just
kind of missed him when we were kids we
didn't watch his shows growing up for
one thing because we didn't have cable
until like the chandlers did yeah right
um we didn't have cable but i i knew of
him and i and i
knew that he was cool and adventurous
yeah and uh maggie loves him yeah and
she
speaks glowingly about it in fact when
maggie hears this i'm sure when she
hears the part where i say oh i was so
excited for this episode i bet you
she'll say probably out loud well you
were excited
i was the one that was yeah in her
defense she was far more excited she
he's one of her heroes there was a part
of me that thought well a guy like that
you'd want to see
his appeal is that when he's with
animals and you want to and or on an
adventure you want to see him doing that
stuff like how fun would it be to hear
him talking about and uh boy was i wrong
because i just loved i could have i just
wanted to keep talking to him he's great
and uh i'm excited for you guys to hear
so let's get into it my
chitty chat
chat chitty ditty chat chat
with jeff
corwin
tried to redo that no that was awesome
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
you grew up in norwell mass is that any
is that how close is that to where you
are now about three miles oh wow so i
live very close to work cool so you must
have known of this island but separated
by an island yes so i wanted to go back
home but i wanted an ocean between yes
so it all worked out great so what was
your perception of that island that you
live on now when you were a kid growing
up in norwell you must have been aware
of it oh very much so i used to come out
here as a kid and i'd fish for striped
bass and shad
and i would come search for arrowheads
and i used to dig for arrowheads and i
remember
when my wife and i we got married 26
years ago
um we were starving students grad
students i was anyways at the time
and i remember would come out here and
we dreamed of living out here some day
so we got married we gave all our
wedding money to the old lady that owned
this house this house
goes back uh this actually used to
belong to uh daniel webster
um and this is
yeah so
um we restored one of the original
structures that was a part of that group
of people but when um my wife and i we
we befriended the little old lady and
would bring her treats and we took all
our wedding money which was like you
know
2500 poison and
we gave it to her so pretty much
poisoned her we bought poison
and um anyway she's done in the basement
under a lot of cement no but um
uh
so we gave her we said listen take your
house off the market
and we're gonna buy it in one year
and if we can't buy it in one year keep
the money and put the house back in the
market and then within that one year was
when my first tv series happened which
was uh on disney channel
so we bought the house what was your
plan jeff what what if that hadn't
happened what how were you going to get
enough money to to buy that place from
the sweet old lady even after you'd
buttered it up i'm sure she wanted money
i've always been a risk taker and i put
it that that's one of the times it
worked out there's a whole list of
things that didn't work out
as you know was business yeah when you
first got on tv was your accent
something that people
cautioned you to neutralize was that
ever like a thing where they're like uh
oh it was usually after you know the gin
and tonics report the new england accent
you know i can be in a certain state be
kind of like your cousin from boston you
know
yeah and then you know they found his
finger in the chowder and you know sort
of thing yeah but but when people say
i'm fascinated by the acts and my
brother's gonna be so mad at me that i'm
taking time talking about your accent um
uh i'm just so hung up on the boston
because so many people do it poorly
what what do you think is the most
common mistake when somebody's doing a
boston accent well they try really hard
number one it's gotta just you gotta act
like you're
an offender bender on route three south
you know pulling over
to the side of the road i think people
try to do the boston accident and it's
usually british people
um that first of all they're trying to
talk like americans and now they're
trying to put on a sort of new england
style dialect
and um it comes off almost like they're
from coney island but i like
you know you know what i'm talking about
sort of that you know yeah a boston
accent is you just kind of just kind of
got to go with it and where it's like
piss uh
you know certain words but then i notice
you also hit your r's sometimes people
are always going uh they don't go to the
ad and over there but you go over there
yeah it's you know what it is they go to
that whole kennedy thing yeah it comes
to kennedy thing my brother john's going
to do great things for this country yes
that's pretty good
you look like you could be a kennedy too
that's pretty good did you have pets and
stuff growing up do you remember your
first memories of really falling in love
with wildlife i was an animal kid since
my first memories
my father was a boston police officer
and my mom was a nurse she worked in
boston in quincy a little town south of
boston
we grew up in the city in the early part
uh we grew up you know in what we call a
triple decker basically an apartment
three apartments jefferson triple decker
triple decker yeah sandwich yeah um
on the weekends would go visit uh my
grandparents that lived in a more rural
setting and when i was six years old i
found my first snake and it was a garter
snake that was it it was like a
lightning bolt really and i knew
that for the rest of my life i would
work with animals i was so intrigued and
fascinated by this legless scaly
creature and the audacity of a little
kid i thought i was like the first one
who ever saw this thing yes yeah i
remember that sense of discovery was so
great oh yeah it was like my discovery
and then i reached down and grabbed that
snake and then it reached back and
grabbed onto me and i came in with this
snake hanging from my arm almost as long
as i was
and uh
my grandmother was like get rid of it
i'm like
and i'm like no i'm not gonna get rid of
it because why not and i said because i
love it now get it off my arm so they
pried this poor snake off my arm and we
liberated it back into the wood pile but
that was kind of like my gateway drug
for animals that was wow the moment i
became a naturalist you know jeff i'm
surprised that a garter snake would do
it because they for those of you who are
a snake a goddard snake yeah got a gun
it's named after the band that you yes
to hold up your socks but they produce
such a an offensive musk that um i'm
surprised that that didn't turn you off
animals that it that it had the opposite
effect it wasn't repellent to you
because that odor i know it's so pungent
you know it yeah i know it well i mean
many gardeners
yeah many snakes do that
it's that repulsive smell that smell of
death that tries to keep predators from
eating them
um no it just and you know it takes
forever to wash that off yes so i know i
had one named merv griffin
yeah but uh no it i mean
you just i was so amazed by this
creature and i actually i named it
gladys and i studied it for like two
years i got a sketchbook i started doing
like anatomies type sketches and
taxonomy sketches wow my first was when
i learned how to read i got my peterson
field guide and then one day i'm
watching this snake and
it's laying out their basking in my
grandmother's backyard and then it was
moment of chaos and i look and the snake
is decapitated and i see the next door
neighbor with the spade and it killed
that snake
and that was the day that i became a
conservationist i often think the day i
became a naturalist was when i was six
years old and i found that garter snake
and the day i focused in on conservation
was when i saw a good person make a bad
decision yeah that person lacked proper
information did you ever have other
snakes as pets like maybe more exotic
snakes or is that something that as part
of your conservation efforts you try to
discourage people from doing well this
was a different time back then and by
the time i was 14 years old i was very
active involved in wildlife
rehabilitation
and in fact i was one of the pioneers
with the group of people worked with the
veterinarian when i was in high school
to do like rehab on animals that were
hit by cars or abandoned or raising baby
birds so by the time i was 14 years old
my bedroom was basically like a
menagerie it was like noah's ark
we had and and then by the time i was
15 years old i was traveling around
doing lectures on snakes and animals so
i was actually going to schools and
camps and all these sorts of things
yeah and by the time i was 16 i was in
central america studying snakes oh my
god in belize right i read that you were
in the rainforest in belize it was a
place i've always wanted to go
had you graduated then from high school
how did that work with your schooling no
i pretty much
gave up on high school when i went the
first day i walked into high school i
was like
uh this isn't for me what was what was
it that that struck you as everything it
was the authority it was the
restrictions
you know the first thing i did was i
found a theater class so the only thing
the uh
in between junior high school and high
school i got one a
and that was from the teacher that said
in my class at the end you can give
yourself a grade and i'm like
you know what i'm going to give myself
an a
yeah no one else is my teachers my
teacher is like so um you feel like
you've earned that a and i said listen i
need all the a's i can guess yeah it was
your policy so so it's like f d d d plus
c minus a oh my god even in science
class even in like biology i flunked
biology class you're kidding no i was
not your classic student
so uh no and i tell people that a lot
because people assume like oh if you
don't study you'll never get to do this
and i would recommend like my two
daughters are remarkable students like
i'm in shock how smart they are and they
get great exam
scores and stuff i was not that kid i
was not a
a classic
uh pedological child when it came to an
educational experience wow so i
basically my mom says the only reason
why i didn't flunk out of high school is
because they could not handle me coming
back
they gave you they gave you great
relationships good enough whatever just
get them out the door yeah
so i yeah i applied to my first college
flunked out of that in like a month
so then i yep then i joined the military
what anyone does so oh my god
you have the best job in the world jeff
i've watched your show and you get to go
all over the world you get to go on
especially the show on the cruise ship
where you stop at a port and you go have
adventures that to me is the ideal
job
is that how you conceived of it were you
just like i want the best version of a
job and i've i'm gonna craft the best
version well i i love to travel and when
you know with the serious ocean tricks
uh what you're talking about the abc
series you know we do typically 20
countries every season
you know the format for it is a nature
culture adventure
you know i love to focus in on stories
that inspire people to have a better
connection to the natural world and to
think about their relationship within
the natural world especially with
sustainability and stewardship
and it's been awesome i also love to
cook and i love culture and
um you know i have a little anthropology
and background in me and i love to
exercise those muscles so that series
has allowed me to do that and ultimately
you know
hopefully we will get back to a point
where we can all explore and travel the
world again and i want to you know
give people tools to be a better
traveler to be a more kinder wiser
explorer the episode i'm thinking of i
guess is the last one i saw so it's
freshest in my mind it hits all of those
points that you're talking about you go
to grand turk which is a place that i'd
been to but i'd been more as a
less conscientious tourist you're
focused on the hawksbill turtle and
uh doing you know collecting data on on
the turtle and that stuff i love you
caught this turtle and then you go
fishing and you catch the fish and a
local woman cooks it and the dr it's
just such a it you're right it hits all
of those beats and um which one would
you recommend to people uh
that maybe was the most
the craziest adventure you went on or
the one that you think is most helpful
well it's you know it
oceantrex is an interesting series
because
i really can't push the conservation
envelope like i would like to right like
i'm working on a series right now
when i can get back in an airplane the
current project i'm working is really
intensively focused in on hey we're the
last generation to make a difference i'm
very excited to get back in those
stories ocean treks is kind of
the idea is to be inspirational and to
have fun but at the same time take a
positive
message away from that journey and i
think i'm trying to think for me what
you know we unlike
uh
something i'm doing we're trying to film
a wild animal in a real moment type
thing
where we may have six weeks to make that
journey these things are wrapped up in
about three or four days wow um
and so it's quick each story's the day
um you know sandwiched by some travel
time but i think i gotta get kind of
lucky then
right there it's a lot of research
a lot of preparation like for the
hawksbill episode would
is that an example i mean did you get
lucky in finding that hawksbill it's
also the largest one they found in the
area one thing that made that sequence
work is that um you know this is
actually what i've done a lot of
it's like oh shoot there's one i want
that one
i can't get it because it's too deep
it's 120 feet and i'm like
i can get it
i'm gonna go down
and and that's the only reason why we
had that scene because i was able to
employ
my skill sets as a field biologist and a
turtle guy and sometimes the stories
don't come through and we have to make
really good tasting lemonade out of
those lemons
but most of the times it's a lot of
preparation but i think a story for me i
love when i get to take my family on the
road it's funny i got i think one of my
favorite ones we did in japan and i
didn't realize that people in japan
watched my shows so i had my teenage
daughter with me at the time she's now
just got accepted to colleges oh she's
that's happening oh wow exciting so is
she gonna study biology
um she's looking at sciences and um
media and and television production huh
there you go so i'm like
i can't help you you're on your own kid
yeah yeah um and um so um
this was a couple years ago so i think
she was 15 and my youngest daughter
marina she was 10.
and so i got invited to be the first um
western scientist non-japanese scientist
to actually physically be a part of
this incredible creature it's the giant
japanese salamander oh yes
so this salamander so this was something
i've dreamed of seeing in the wild
since i was
um
seven eight years old so now i'm
in my early 50s and i get a chance to
find this creature so yeah we show up
there and there are all these i see all
these like college kids there and i'm
like why do they need so many kids and
these were all people that have watched
my shows so this
young japanese college kid goes up to
mine and goes you know sort of like you
don't know how
really lucky you are your father you
know he has has seen this he's done this
and she just looks she goes well you
don't know him like that
but that moment when i was with this
incredible
highly respected
japanese uh biologist who i've admired
his work i get to be his sidekick and
then before you know it my hands are on
this dream dragon
you know this nearly four foot long
endangered salamander and then we talk
about it and how they protect it
is they protect it like a national
monument i want to get back to the giant
salamander where how do they protect it
and i love the idea that it's it's
something that they're all proud of and
where did you find this one
krypto brancus is the scientific name
there's only three surviving species
they go back
350 million years that's how old they
are we actually have one surviving
species in the united states it's called
the hellbent hellbender yep and they get
about this big
yeah how are about that big are you at
all impressed that i knew that i i mean
i mean not huge but it's something to be
proud of this big it's a good size
hellbender and they live in streams
right like fascinating
cold water highly oxygenated
streams in the west and midwest
uh
you're doing pretty good dude yeah like
i have to i'm oppressed
and i wanted to search
well i was i was like you i i went a
different way but i loved all this stuff
when i was a kid um
and i and i've been reading a lot about
the yanks is it the yangtze newt the
chinese
the no the one that went extinct um
because
that's something we should talk about
how many of these especially amphibians
because their skin is so sad how many go
extinct and have have been and are now
threatened um is am i getting that right
the chinese river newt there's many um
we've lost about 20
of our amphibians we will lose
60 of our amphibians within our
lifetimes amphibians are the ultimate
canary in the coal mine for our planet
they've survived five major extinctions
but most of them will not survive
the sixth extinction which is us
and because of climate change
environmental degradation habitat loss
in this i'm sure you've heard of this
deadly fungus
called frog fungus yes kitrid yeah but
recto kidrian mycosis is this deadly
fungus that gets in their skin basically
it's athlete's foot on steroids and it
gets in their
skin and it causes the skin to callous
as you mentioned then they can no longer
breathe through their skin cutaneous
respiration and we have seen a mass
extinction unfolding but unfortunately
it is this invisible extinction yeah
and you know these are keystone species
these are critical to the survival of
ecosystems i did a documentary
a few years ago for animal planet called
the vanishing frog we traveled around
the world and we documented the plight
trying to to
show the world what we're facing and i
it really bothered me that even after
this documentary was made no one really
gave a crap why is that do you think i
think because it's not a big sexy panda
or a tiger
yeah and frankly i don't know how many
people how many people care even today
about that we're so caught up
in politics and whatever we don't
realize that our world is imploding
around us with regard to our global and
national natural heritage and ultimately
we will pay the price i mean
we have consumed
in about 45 years
60 percent of the nature of our planet
god in heaven so credible we only have
40 of our
pristine natural world left and when i
say that that's everything from an
individual animal
to an ecosystem and the life forms that
make that up is now gone impress upon
people why they should care about frogs
and and what you mean by the canaries in
the coal mine that what about their skin
makes them extra sensitive to
environmental degradation because they
rely on moist healthy aerosol
environments to breathe
because they need certain temperatures
will affect them
their membranes or their skin is quick
to absorb chemicals
when we see changes in the environment
they're the first to tell us that
they're the the kind of like the natural
barometer of what's
happening in our world it's what we call
an indicator species
so when you see an entire class of
species that have withstood the test of
time
literally
disappear right before our very eyes
yeah and i tell you it is quite shocking
i i went into a rain forest that i first
visited um as a very young man in my
early 20s late teens
and i walked into this rainforest now
in my early 40s
and i walked in
and i'm like it it's postcard perfect
rainforest what's freaking wrong with
this picture here you know i'm looking
around trying to you can't hear the
frogs that's it the babbling stream
everything is coming together but the
amphibians are gone there's not one
single surviving amphibian yeah and if
you look at our planet right now
we're seeing three distinct
group of keystone species that are in
serious jeopardy amphibians bats insects
especially our pollinators
europe has lost
minimally 50 percent of all their
pollinators
we're in trouble in this country
so we're seeing the building blocks of
nature
and the ultimate indicators of the
health of our ecosystems
collapse
so what does that say for everything
else
so jeff that must have been frustrating
to to see all the attention that that
murder hornet was getting earlier in the
pandemic that that became um
that that's something that receives
national attention and only probably
stands to further vilify a species like
that was that
was that frustrating to you and do you
wish that
this this bigger picture issue would get
as much attention
the only stories that are going to make
it are the most sensationalistic views
anything that competes with the 24-hour
you know incredibly wild news cycle of
what we're hopefully wrapping up in a
box and sinking to the bottom of the
well
what makes the news it's the murder
hornet what makes the news the guy that
survives you know the mountain lion
attack
there's nothing
meanwhile there's been incredible
amounts of science
discoveries incredible uh challenges
with the environment um i mean what kind
of made the news was like hey guess what
when when we shut off the human species
earth begins to recover you know fish
show up in venice coral reefs will look
a little better migrating animals start
returning i think it is an amazing csi
story how holy crap this deadly murder
hornet which it shouldn't be called that
because
it's not really a murder hornet but you
don't want that out competing our native
species
so the idea that they literally went and
put on and found them and literally
found the hive
and likely have secured that invading
new colony i mean it's kind of an
incredible story
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining onedri plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
i'm so fascinated uh and morbidly
curious about extinct species and
species that i remember when i was a kid
and i remember seeing a dodo bird at the
natural history museum and and we'd
never see a living one again
what are some species that we can focus
on now that still have a chance that
might be a little bit more like you
mentioned the panda that might encourage
people to
care more about conservation i also
think it's about a a
a refocusing of re-education about
learning the importance of these little
but a very vital
very uh critical species
saying yeah it's very important that we
protect an iconic species like a bengal
tiger but did you know that 50
of all
the flora all the plant species in the
sonoran desert are pollinated by bats
did you know that
60
of all the rain forest trees and plants
are pollinated and have their their
seeds dispersed because of bats
one tiny little
new england brown bat in an evening
consumes
1400 mosquitoes mosquitoes that carry
triple e
and zika and and and other insect
vectored
diseases
so in one colony
of of brown bats 1k full of brown bats
consumes
40 dump truck worth
a year of
insect pests think of that benefit to
agriculture to human health to the
environment yes the human annoyance yes
yeah think about all the barbecues that
are saved yes yeah and all the
margaritas that are survived
um i remember a moment that really hit
me is i covered the gulf oil spill for
nbc was embedded in that story literally
and um
they liked what i was doing so they
started having me doing some other
stories so i did the story about this
massive bat extinction caused by white
nose syndrome which is a fungus that's
right exactly very good you touch your
nose that's it yes this was about what
10 years ago yeah and it's still
happening again we don't talk about it
but it's still there
so we walked into this cave system in
baton kill vermont
it's actually the baton kill river cool
historic river actually the orvis fly
fishing school is on that river
um
and so we went into this cave system the
year before it had 250 000 bats we found
12 remaining bats and i kept wondering
why there was a carpet of pine needles
on a carpet this thing of pine needles
on the floor of the cave and i thought
how the hell did all these pine needles
is because of the bats and it wasn't
pineas it was all the bat finger bones
oh from the dead bats oh my god
we spent
days crafting that story and in the last
minute
nbc news didn't air the story because
there was a sexier story to tell
see yeah i remember for like weeks and
weeks i'm like please that story is so
important
so we lose the species um
once every half an hour on our oh my
gosh god wow
but you know
there are there's incredible stories of
hope when it comes to species my
favorite story is the black-footed
ferret the black-footed ferret is our
only true
ferret in north america
they only eat one thing
prairie dogs ah
and they live inside the prairie donk
what's called a prairie dog town
and prairie dogs are a keystone species
because they are important resource for
many predators
and they also provide habitat for all
sorts of animals that inhabit the
subterranean world of a prairie dog
when we started vilifying prayer duck we
actually created machines that look like
you know something you know out of uh
stephen burr steve spielberg's war of
the worlds we'd
be evacuated
suck up the prairie dogs like flush them
down a toilet a prairie dog and
exactly a prairie dog vacuum or you know
and it was and some of it was because of
the issues with livestock
people worried that they could carry
disease right most of these were
incorrect reasons but they wiped them
out to the point that the prairie dog
could no longer sustain this um
black-footed ferret which only ate them
and they became extinct they literally
were gone
well lo and behold a rancher in wyoming
his dog in the 1970s dropped a dead
black-footed ferret at his doorstep this
guy had the wherewithal to take this to
a local u.s fish and wildlife office
they went to his property they found
literally the lost surviving colony
my god 100 animals
they were declared extinct
as fate would have it
somehow they were exposed it was i can't
remember is either distemper or plague
within a few weeks the population was
reduced to 11. wow
and they created this you know
artificial world to try to salvage them
i filmed them 26 years ago
and there was only a very few that and
it was kind of really is the glass half
full yeah they're all you know
are they ever going to live in the wild
but we try to do a spin on it this is my
first jeff did they keep them in that
wild environment did they keep them on
the ranch they brought them on they work
with zeus the denver zoo the national
zoo the whole zoo community came
together to try to restore them at the
u.s fish and wildlife service but
basically there was like a head start
program wow for these um black-footed
ferrets cut to
how many years later two decades later
my daughter now who's um
a senior in high school back then she's
six years old she's by my side we each
along with uh 12 other people have a
little ha you know carrie cage we're in
wind cave national park in south dakota
we open up the door out jumps this very
pugnacious unappreciated appreciative
you know blackfoot affair you know we
kind of like go on little buddy and he's
kind of got
like that
and then he kind of slinks off towards
the prairie dog town and all these
prairie dogs are like
why the hell did you do that well
they're not used to their back they're
they probably did they have a natural
instinct to run away because they
probably weren't used to there hadn't
been a black footed fairy fared around
for so long they were like oh they knew
that they knew they were they knew they
were screwed they knew they were over so
you released
back into the
we released 14 yeah those those prairie
dogs no no they were over the prairie
dog pickle barrel they were in trouble
they they had a nice long vacation free
from blackberries
so these 14 black-footed farts go into
there 14
of 2 000
that now survive in the wild it's a
recovered species it's amazing so i look
at them as kind of like the lazarus
yes
endangered species if you can take an
endangered species and bring it back
yeah
you know there's always hope now are sea
snakes the most are they the most toxic
of the venomous snakes
they are the most venomous snake there
is
um
like
a number of pacific sea snakes have
enough
just
one
bite
of a medium-bodied sea snake can kill
250 adult men oh my god
well
now when you were around snakes like
that or like a king cobra a mamba or
something really
uh gnarly how do you
how do you handle that fear
well i did my graduate work on snakes
and i did my graduate work and i should
preface this that although i was a
horrible horrible high school student
i went to college and then i went to
graduate school and i did very well
because i was going to say jeff how are
you how did you become a biologist if
you were like if you're like a dropout i
i i stayed at a holiday inn once oh yeah
okay you get it when you leave when i
focused in what i loved to do yeah and i
learned how to learn
um and you know i joined the national
guard and i became a medic and i loved
exercising my brain a little bit
and i realized man you just got to think
you maybe don't learn the way other
people do yeah um and i got accepted to
college before i
did any sort of uh service and um i
flunked out like that and so when i
finally went back
did my second chance i went to
bridgewater state
uh bridgewater which is now bridgewater
state university
they accepted they said you can only
take three courses
because i just had no structure yeah and
but by the time i graduated i graduated
the degree in biology and a degree in
anthropology and then went on to grad
school bridgewater bridgewater and then
i went on to umass amherst for graduate
school which was a wonderful school
anyone wants to go to a great school to
study nature and science both of those
schools are awesome and what was your
concentration there jeff you said you
had kind of honed in on something was it
herpetology so
uh so i studied when i went to graduate
school i did i literally returned to the
rainforest
of my youth and did graduate work on
bats and i did an inventory of reptiles
and amphibians of that area
so of course luck would have it on my
last day in the field
on my way out i saw a coral snake and i
went to capture that coral snake
that last coral snake bit me on my toe
oh my god and i almost died i bet yeah
they're wow wow they are the most
venomous new world snake they are in the
same family as sea snakes the family
called a lapiday they're a neurotoxic
fixed fanged snake now what does
neurotoxin do it attacks the brain it
arrests the nervous system
your respiratory system your heart so
what did you feel how did you feel what
what described this inside i was like oh
my god you are such an idiot why did you
try to catch a coral snake you blended
on gods i blamed it on god
but physiologically what was happening
to you what was the sensation like first
of all the pain was exquisite
all right at my i was literally bit on
my pinky toe
and the pain effect was incredible
and so after a very colorful moment of
verbiage
i said dude you need to figure out how
you're going to live because
you have a couple of hours before i go
into cardiac arrest and where were you
jeff on a mountain in belize i was about
a six mile hike from the nearest anybody
oh my god so and then i started feeling
the pain and i started feeling like an
arrhythmia
i my mucous membranes so it wasn't
psychosomatic i'm like dude you are
pickle barrelled and you're by yourself
and you're sick i'm all by myself and i
just put on a focus and i said okay if i
go this way
i can get someone who will take me to
town
if i go the other way if i go west i'm
going to go to an indian village where i
know it's a very remote mopey uh quechua
mayan village
they live very traditionally no
electricity
but they were building a school it was
like a mission group of high school kids
and they had a a radio
so and they were british i went there
they got on their radio they called the
british embassy the british embassy sent
a helicopter they literally strapped me
to the skid of the helicopter thank god
they took me to the hospital had i done
the other route i would have died
because they had no anti-venom at the
place i would have gone to in punta
gorda so you had to do the quick
mathematical you had to do this yeah i
was like all right statistically what
are my best chances wow so i get to the
husband police
they
i was within an hour
maybe half an hour of expiring put me on
the ante venom
and within
a few hours i was feeling
stabilized
and i remember the
us ambassador
came
or the consulate general came and his
wife came they literally took care of me
and i remembered i remember they brought
this long phone
when they thought i wasn't going to make
it
and the ambassador said i'm going to
call your wife i've been married for
three months oh my god
don't forget to pack your vet anti-venom
yeah yeah don't forget your anti-venom
yes
it's a terrible impression of your wife
and and your cutter spray for the
mosquitoes yeah
so so they thought you were doc i mean
you must have looked they thought there
was a chance that i wouldn't survive and
so he called my wife
he said mrs corwin
you know i'm with your husband it's not
looking very good
she was so mad she didn't want to talk
to me
and at that time i had a large
collection of snakes
so um wait wait i hear him i hear him
back at home and she was forced to take
care of her
insult
yeah and these were my educational
critters at the time years ago so she's
on the phone with him
and uh
he goes uh yes he's right here and he
goes oh okay
would you like me to give him a message
and he goes
which i've never heard this word i
remember i've never heard anyone go
naturally like who uses the word
naturally
in a conversation yeah and he said uh
okay you want me to say that okay yeah
goodbye mrs corwin he said
your wife wants you to know that before
you die she wants you to imagine
her
cutting off the heads of all your effing
snakes
that's my wife
that's my goyal
which means the ambassador after he
heard her say that was like well
naturally you would is that the context
in which he was using it naturally you'd
cut off all their heads a hot ticket
isn't she she's got a lot of gumption
i'm surprised you've lasted three months
so once you were all better obviously
you recovered did you talk about her i
literally called her back like an hour
later i'm like are you serious she says
what were you thinking my parents my
parents everyone was so scared and so
furious because they all knew what
really happened everyone thought i was
just hiking in the woods and i somehow
stumbled upon and stepped on a coral
snake and was bitten
they all knew the truth that i was not
being careful being
this young
buck hot in the jungles yeah
from norwell looking for his snakes
lesson learned lesson learned but was
the light did you have do you have
hiking boots on what's the lesson
the lesson well the lesson learned is
that i'm mortal i i now look at them in
a very different way is it hard for you
to be around coral snakes
not at all wow but what was amazing talk
about
a cathartic full circle
moment so for a few years ago in another
series i had we went to this incredible
venom institute in san jose costa rica
and
i got to help
milk these snakes and if you you can
actually see me milk this fertilizer
it's about this fat wow
right it's a pit vibe things are this
long
and you could fill a martini glass with
the venom it was so much wow
so i ended up
bumping into the scientists who actually
manufactured the anti-venom that saved
my life
and he knew about my story about my case
god so and the crazy thing about coral
snakes um describe the color patterns
because i know they're very similar to a
completely harmless name called the king
snake right yeah there's a number it's
you have uh apostomatic coloration so
think of a monarch butterfly it has
these bright colors that say if you eat
me i'm poisonous
to oppose and and coral snakes have this
vivid you know literally it's like a
stop like yellow slow down red you
better stop um and black makes them pop
even more
and um so then you have what's called
batesian mimicry animals that imitate
venomous snake creatures or poisonous or
toxic creatures to get that benefit so
the viceroy butterfly looks almost like
a monarch but it is completely palatable
there are many many king snakes
and other snakes that mimic that
coloration but what's interesting is you
can't realize so like in central america
red touches yellow kill a fellow red
touches black friend of jack
same thing in north america
but it's completely reversed
in south america for many species oh my
god lie in that oh my god well you were
in central america a place that i was
fascinated by when i was a kid and and
in part because of the beauty of a lot
of their poison arrow frogs a lot of
their tree frog species and um one of my
favorite the golden toad i was wondering
if you were ever around when the golden
toad existed it's a species that's now
that's since been extinct i think for
like 30 years but
i i wonder if you ever got to see one
remember that national uh
geographic photo of bright beautiful
orange frog
and it's sitting i think in it
and and i remember thinking i'm never
going to see that i'm never going to see
that because it's extinct i thought the
same thing and the closest i got to that
is i filmed the golden um
frog
adelopi's various which looks it's the
same group actually it's the same genus
and this was in panama
this species became extinct in the wild
it was so prevalent and so common
that the um ancient indigenous people of
panama used them as they actually made
little gold emblems of them and used
them as currency
and and
it actually became extinct
you know
we were complete adults when it became
extinct wow and
i went down with the scientists to film
this lab they created and this is in
this documentary the vanishing frog i
gotta see this
where they actually created a lab in the
middle of the jungles where they
literally was like a noah's ark they got
the last couples
so what it was the ultimate irony of
nature they had found female golden
frogs they were actually dying because
they were filled with eggs
but they could not express the eggs
because they need to do what's called
implexis where the male comes and he
pushes the eggs out and then he
fertilizes those eggs they couldn't
complete that task so they were actually
dying from being egg bound so me
and this
scientist friend of mine that i've known
for many years we went out and we
searched and we searched and we searched
and we found
i was with him when he found
the last surviving adult male
golden toad and that then went back to
the center you mean the frog
the golden frog
see i always makes him a toad and frog
sorry i would say adelopius various okay
he found the last one wow that was a
male and i remember that moment when he
revealed it lucky man we took that lucky
him lucky all of us lucky frog yeah and
by the way toads are frogs so we can
switch that back and forth he brought
that individual back and that restarted
the population to breed in captivity
amazing and now
in my local franklin park zoo
where my dad when he was a cop would
drop me off and i'd go help the
zookeeper you used to do that back then
you can't drop your kid anymore who can
help a zookeeper but back then you could
back in the day
and so that frog
i went there
to give a speech a few years ago and
they were breeding the frogs
from panama
from this guy
who discovered the last surviving one
wow the irony is they can't be put back
into the wild now why until we have us
because of kitrid the kitrid oh [ __ ] so
that's the fungus
that's the fungus god that's another
great example of a lazarus story yes oh
i love these stories god oh jeff this is
so interesting um too much to talk about
uh
i i j this is a very i'm wondering if
you can help me out with like a very
personal thing and
and and please forgive me if if i did
something
wrong uh a painted turtle laid some eggs
on my property in massachusetts last
summer and
they weren't hatching i i waited the
requisite amount of time the incubation
period and i went and looked and they
had all and i guess this happens with
turtles sometimes they climb they dig
out of their shells but they can't get
out of the ground it does yeah so i
retrieved them and i decided it was too
cold now
so i kept them in in the hopes of then
repopulating them putting them kidnapped
them i kidnapped them yes i i turtle nap
them but i'm what my plan is is to
release them in the springtime they just
seem so vulnerable jeff don't look at me
like judging me uh so i
i um
what would your recommendation be are
they now too domesticated to release
again can a painted turtle survive after
they've been kept in captivity so i i
think
first of all
painted turtles are a beautiful
wonderful
very abundant species of turtle so it's
not like it was a blanding's turtle or
a box turtle or something box turtles
are a little less in trouble but i never
seen thanks for turtles i know
blanding's turtles um wood turtles uh
and uh oh my gosh a bog turtles oh yeah
beautiful spotted turtles
spotted turtles are doing pretty good
it's funny we used to think spotted
turtles were critically endangered yeah
and then they discovered
that cranberry bogs are filled with them
oh it was one of these recent things
they really just they discovered but
landings in new england especially
massachusetts blanding's turtles and bog
turtles are only in the hundreds of
surviving individuals wow but
you know painted turtles are very very
uh
robust and successful so we can assume
the native population
heavily dented from your
your love
your thanks for quality
yeah but i would say that they will be
perfectly fine so could you hatch them
out
no i i took them as hatchlings they
hatched naturally they just couldn't get
out they weren't getting out of the
ground i don't know how long they had
been in there you have them in your
house now yes you don't have to worry
about conditioning them to be you know
their behavior they're hardwired to be
turtles okay the only thing you would
have to be concerned about when baby
turtles hatch out
they have very specific needs for
nutrition
um for calcium to ensure healthy uh
shell growth yeah they also need to have
proper uv light yeah
so as as long as their diet is okay okay
and you're not over or under feeding
them and their shells are growing
correctly okay
then they will be perfectly fine so i
would say in the world of conservation
negligence
um you know
this is very low in the radar screen you
know when i take
what you've done with these turtles and
i look at the pebble mine in alaska it's
they're pretty okay oh i wouldn't wear
i'm on the other end of the spectrum
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
you may hear jeff go in and out on his
microphone he's having some microphone
issues but um bear with us for the
remainder of this um
this episode we're going regular now
how's that a couple other specific
things i wanted to ask you about you
were attacked by an elephant in 2007 uh
on a cnn special can you describe i mean
in retrospect
what would you have done differently
what could you have done differently and
and how frightening an experience was
that that was probably one of the most
frightening
moments i've had with an animal in my
entire career
far more terrifying than being
bitten by a coral snake really it
happened so quickly
and so dramatically
and i was with anderson cooper at the
time
that i had worked with cnn to create
called planet in parallel it was an idea
i had since i was like a teenager
hosted by anderson cooper sanjay gupta
and myself
and we traveled around the world and
anders and i traveled around together
and kind of looked at what was wrong
with the planet
and also we want to see who looked
better in a t-shirt well yeah i was
going to say way to bury the lead yeah
and um
we were there we were filming at this
place called nam tamao and cambodia a
place i had filmed that many many times
i had exclusive access to these animals
incredible we're doing hands-on
conservation work and then with these
rescue elephants
and we were with them bathing them in
the river having a good time
i have been working with elephants all
around the world i've never had
a major situation with an elephant i was
talking interested about something i
felt my left arm going behind me
and i will tell you it's only
really since the last couple of years i
actually
talk about it without getting upset
about i used to physically
get ill when i would think about it oh
my god because i was so terrified and
with such pain so thank you for bringing
up that drama
you sound so cool about this elbow
i felt his trunk
pull me up like that i didn't think any
i pulled it away and pulled it away
and then finally
you know an elephant's trunk
is so strong it could knock down a giant
rainforest tree oh my gosh it's so
sensitive they can pick up a grain of
rice wow um
and but this thing i remember feeling it
like a like a
blood pressure cup
twist like this i went oh that's a new
thing and he actually pulled she pulled
my elbow into her mouth
and bit down on it and then crushed my
whole arm high squeal with such pain and
then began to ragdoll me oh my and i
knew see
i think we were always clowning around i
tend to be a bit of a clown on the in
the field
and every i don't know if for about five
seconds people thought it was a joke oh
my and that guy
knew it was real and then
they all came in and got her to release
me i kind of shook it off and we went
back into the whole thing i knew i was
in trouble i was in a lot of pain so i
we i they i went back to uh
phnom penh the capital of cambodia saw a
doctor i had was a compression injury
which literally everything got squished
but everything was in place so i just
had to keep it in place and it all
healed fine
but it was a very powerful moment it
took a long
long time for me to
feel comfortable about elephants again
and i don't think it was my fault i
don't think it was the elephant's fault
i think there's always a risk with
wildlife yeah you know this was the
story we're telling and it went south
jeff what do you think it was that
provoked i mean in retrospect i mean
what would your diagnosis be of it your
like forensic uh final analysis of why
that animal did i think it was an
elephant that had enough it had enough
of the cameras it had enough of you know
it's like a tv's like oh oh man i want
to do that again or yeah you know the
guy's like elephants are ready to go eat
i'm like oh we just need two more
seconds with the elephants in the river
um yeah whatever it was it just the
elephant just be like you know for the
elephant to be like you know i kind of
like this guy for about 10 minutes he's
right i'm over it oh he's kind of like a
mosquito
yeah he's showing off with anderson
cooper and who looks better
so i'm gonna get rid of it yeah well it
it's just you know stuff happens within
animals are wild yeah and
they behave the way they behave and they
don't always you know fit in the human
toy box i'm now seeing all of these
experiences through the lens or as much
as i can through the lens of your wife i
mean from the coral snake incident to
the elephant and and i imagine when um
steve irwin died that must have been
awake at some sort of
wake up and and that must have been
traumatic for you uh doing a very
similar thing how is your wife how has
she adapted to your
to the chances that you're taking and
these adventures that you go on well
she's developed a tick she's okay
um
you know it's always been that way it's
like literally we got married i left a
week later and was in central america
studying
doing my research yeah without shoes um
and so
it's
pre-coveted i'm on the road
you know eight to ten months out of the
year does she come with you ever
used to more now we have uh kids in high
school and you know it's like anything
it's like oh come with me to africa and
you're gonna spend your whole day in a
tent while i'm out doing this right
because
you know you know i remember filming we
were filming these incredible
chimpanzees that hunk columbus monkeys
oh my god and um
i wanted to document this moment where
these chimps exercise this incredible
predatory
war-like behavior and it only been
filmed once or twice before wow and i
remember i was like speaking to the
production company i'm like oh i'm gonna
bring my family and they'll just stay in
the house and they're like no you can't
bring your kids i'm like well come on
this is you know
it's in the budget for them to travel
for so many trips genetically they're
close to chimps
it's just like they're like it's not
safe i'm like what do you mean it's not
safe he said
last week a group of the chimps came
through pulled a baby off a woman's back
and ate the baby up in the canopy i'm
like maybe they'll stay home oh my god
eat them oh
barney god barney
so it's like you know there are many
times where it's hurry up and wait and
you know you're working a 12-hour
15-hour day
it's
what they'll often do sometimes is come
at the end of the trip
or now what i'll do is i'll pull my kid
into a show
and if they want to be a part of it they
get to be a part of the journey and i
bring them individually so my youngest
daughter marina loves to do them loves
to be a part of it oh you were talking
about steve irwin so what was that like
so
i remember i was filming in gnome alaska
oh
and and at that time noam alaska had a
chinese restaurant a sushi restaurant
and an italian restaurant and a sub shop
they were all the same restaurants no
way
yeah yes
and um that's funny so i remember hear
this knock in the door at like two
o'clock in the morning and it was some
guy there part of a group looking for
gold
jeff gore when you hear about steve
irwin i'm like what he goes
he just this stranger woke me up i woke
up my producer who was there and when
some guy just knocked in the door and
since you know steve irwin
has just died i was absolutely shocked
and then the phone started ringing
and um it was
totally totally surreal and
you know a horrible horrible event and
and just such a random seeming thing
considering all the things he went
through and saw and the dangerous
situations he was in did that give you
pause that
did that
do anything to deter you from some of
the situations you were putting yourself
in it didn't give me pause because i'll
tell you by that point
i had been in two plane crashes that
summer what eight months before that we
had navigated survival in a coup d'etat
and south where asia where in what
country oh in thailand uh it was uh in
cambodia
we were filming there i've been there
many times and we were doing a whole
story on black market wildlife trade and
while we were there thailand
and cambodia had fisticuffs
before we knew it
the u.s embassy burnt down
they burnt down our hotel
all our passports were at the thai
embassy
because we needed to get visas for
something
and we sent our fixer in
to look through the ashes
he got attacked it was
wild and so you know
we've had moments like that yeah
i mean i was literally my at the time my
was three years old
my wife was next to me we were in a
plane the engine blew and we're about to
make an emergency landing in brooks
falls alaska
so
we've survived that stuff
life is going to do what life is going
to do so i i never said
man i need to be more careful yeah
unless
you know you live your life you do your
best and what happens happens how do you
feel about do you ever think about the
afterlife and you you're in all these
perilous situations you might you've
come so close to it do you think it is
is the afterlife or
something for the the beyond anything
that you
certainly don't fixate on it but do you
think about it i don't think about that
i don't look at the world that way i
think
this is your moment and you make the
best out of this moment for me i don't
speak for anybody else yeah
and i think
i want to make my life the best
my family's life the best
an afterlife for me is
is creating an
environment where that next generation
will inherit
a
viable
biologically rich and healthy planet
that is my opportunity of contributing
in my own small little way i can't
imagine there's anything above and
beyond
what i have experienced and what i hope
to experience more with my projects that
i'm working on now
what is there for me
after this life
that's better than this life yeah that
makes sense especially considering the
things you've seen so then um i want
just i want as much of it as
joyful and healthily and physically to
participate in as one can get
in a very small human lifespan
okay really quick jeff lightning round
we have a quick
knee-jerk whatever response what is your
most commonly used emoji if you do use
emojis
i just started using emojis last week oh
congratulations people would send them
to me
and i would be like oh how do you put
that
smiley face or you know the the thumbs
there's a bald eagle emoji and well i
didn't realize until last week
oh that's what that is that's how you do
it
i was afraid to ask people because i
would come across as technologically so
um you're still on your training wheels
your
i use the thumbs up oh like yeah classic
thumbs up classic
that that's good for me thumbs up um if
you could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play i love to swim i
would love to be a
i love when i'm swimming good and i'm
strong and i often to get through my
laps i think like
michael phelps just trailing jeff cool
what are you doing
oh that's yeah um
did you swim in high school
when you were in i didn't but i started
swimming in college and
i'm
i'm i'm i'm pretty sucky at a lot of
sports
in fact i was asked to throw a ball up
for the pittsburgh pirates and my wife
didn't want to go because she couldn't
handle it not making it to the diamond
so uh you didn't think you'd make it
practicing me my friend was in the
living room and i'm like
do i do an underhand hitting lamps and
my wife's like i'm not going
and i'm getting it across the plate oh
i'd be worried about that too because it
could be it's the the downside is much
uh greater than than any potential
upside upside is you get it over the big
deal worried i would have a fouchy
moment yes that was pretty rough that
was important but um no i i was off with
sports but i was really good at swimming
and then when i started to swim
aggressively and actively and then
became i became i got into free diving
yeah wow and uh so i i always i always
need that when i'm doing laps i need
that mental thing to get me
get me through it you're a red sox fan
when they're winning yeah patriots well
not this year oh yeah
sometimes yeah i am yeah i like uh we
we're we've got awesome sportsmen yeah
you sure do um if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life uh
your go-to you're watching a movie you
just want to munch on something what do
you what do you choose
my wife's laughing
these jerky pistachios
or my my homemade roasted peanuts
i roast my own peanuts and they are the
best no how do you roast a peanut on a
skillet on the stove and you kind of
toast the oh so i learned it in
southeast asia like when they make pad
thai they just roast them on this flat
surface or
sometimes central america they do what's
on a on a kamal
so i just do it i buy the raw peanuts
valencia
red skin on peanuts okay and then i love
they're like my go-to kind of like you
talk a little seasoning
i had no see i had no seasoning to them
because the salt doesn't really stick to
it but i i'll chop up like a little bit
of organic beef jerky to it and i like
that flavor of the nuts
that's kind of my go-to snack i'm a i'm
a uh an apple guy i love a great
new england macintosh apple
macintosh yeah people have been saying
honey crisp for whatever reason i think
they must be in season honey crisp i
feel like i need to go to the dentist
after i have a honeycrisp okay all right
apple that's a circus that's like one of
the marshmallow circus peanuts with an
apple skin around it it's just too sweet
it's too deserty
it's decadent uh what's your favorite
movie sequel of all time you know my
favorite movies blade runner
jaws
what else
it no not it
it kisses it
she was right about this jerky though
i'm a star wars
i love
probably
return of the jedi empire strokes back
um what is your go-to karaoke song it
would probably
be uh
a neil diamond song oh me too yeah i am
i said is a great one you know coming to
america oh get the shirt out going yes
yeah you know fantastic and it's in your
reign yeah yeah yeah that'd probably be
it something like that maybe a good
journey song welcome to yeah that's
great um who who is your he might have
to be a surreptitious about this who was
your first celebrity crush i hope she
doesn't answer this one
kristen scott thomas oh yeah english
baby
i remember kristen scott thomas
she's still a very incredibly stunning
beautiful woman yeah but kristen scott
thomas and the english patient oh yeah
yeah and classy and it's a fun name to
hear you say kristen scott thomas
kristen scott thomas
that's great if you had to get a tattoo
what would you get and where where on
your body
uh well i have two tattoos oh oh
i have my coral snake tattoo
do you really
yeah it's my coral snack
oh because you survived it yeah oh this
is the doppelganger
oh my god you have a kit that's a king
snake yeah that's the doppelganger oh my
god i can't believe you didn't lift
those up before when we were talking
about coral snakes and king snakes
jeff just exposed a coral snake on one
bicep red and black
impressive biceps yeah the red and black
or red yellow killer fellow
red and black friend of jack that's
amazing and then in my back i have one
big sea turtle and then she's laying
eggs where the where the uh [ __ ] stamp
would be in this
get out of here wait why i i meant to
ask you how did it bite through your
shoe were you not wearing shoes i was
wearing teethers tivas
yes whoa jesus um okay i don't want to
get into it but my wife just said
dumbass
well in her defense
um
what's your favorite fruit you must have
had the best fruit on your adventures
just the ripest blah blah blah
the best have you ever been to vietnam
i'm dying to go but no i've never been
so i love a lot of fruit i love there's
nothing like a really ripe mango oh yeah
in vietnam they have this thing looks
like a grapefruit it's called the pomelo
and you can peel the whole thing off so
you get nothing but you know the thing
is stinks about a grapefruit orange is
you guys deal with the piss yeah the
rind
so they pull it all out
so you just have the pulp kernels the
juicy parts of this pomelo
and they make a salad with like peanuts
and chilies and dried shrimp wow and
it's the best wow my fa i love
southeastern my favorite food
is like a a papaya salad if you have a
papaya yeah yeah yeah there's a um um
they call it uh yeah there's a great um
there's a great restaurant in la next
time you're there you may have been
called jitlada it's um very authentic
it's the only time i've i've had like
really authentic thai food have you
heard of that shitload of anyway
i think i've probably been there you've
been to the actual places what am i
telling you about good thai food um
who who do you want to play you and you
in your biopic the jeff corwin story
marina who do you think should play play
me in a biopic
justin long
that's the good answer
thank you marina
nice that's very nice i i got to work on
the accent the accent's so subtle uh no
i i don't know
oh maybe i don't know leonardo dicaprio
leonardo dicaprio yeah i thought you
were i don't know
um who's your favorite simpsons
character i imagine if you like the
simpsons i love the simpsons um
probably
mo i love him
yeah
mommy i love barney i love how barney
where they ever see like how barney
becomes an alcoholic do you remember
that episode yes yes when you do the
time lapse yes and at the end they
showed like this he's like at harvard
you know he's like well hope i'm at
harvard university proper yeah he's all
proper and then they he has his first
beer and you time lapse yeah and then
and at the end you see this withering
iris and he says don't cry for me i'm
already dead
uh
i you know i love i love them all
it was very funny so my kids got in this
so i watched every simpson uh-huh
i'm you know
got to do a table read with the simpsons
oh never turned into anything got them
into a table never ended up on it i hope
they're listening but um my kids found
it and
and they went
dad
there's a show called the simpsons you
would really like it i'm like
uh okay
i invented that show
i play mayor quimby
yeah
um dogs are cats i think i might know
this but which which do you prefer well
we have two dogs okay cats um
i've always loved cats i was never a dog
person
and then my wife she got our first dog
and i'm like i like dogs they're pretty
cool so now i am a dog person but i like
i like i love our cats love our both you
still have snakes you still have snakes
nothing you know um
i you know for me i think first of all
there's no time for that i also
get enough of it
working all day and i really think
there has to be a legitimate reason so
i'm not teaching with them i'm not doing
wildlife rehab i'm not doing any stuff
yeah so i i prefer to see them you know
in the wild and stuff like that my
daughter she has
a pet theater dragon oh cool
you have mango oh okay oh cool um well
if she ever wants a painted turtle
there's enough people breaking laws with
nature
i'm sorry i'm returning them i'm
returning them uh i looked up daniel
webster and apparently his last words
were i still live
which i thought was really cool and in
terms of the work you do and and the
amount of education that you're offering
to the world your your work will always
live and and
uh in in the most important way so i i
can't thank you enough for doing that
for your work and for taking the time to
talk to me well thank you very much i
had a lot of fun and
and hopefully i hope people realize that
there are brighter days ahead now we can
start refocus there's no excuse for us
all to focus on the mission at hand
we have a lot of opportunity out of out
of all this negativity is opportunity to
really make a difference i think this is
going to be an incredible year
and it's about ensuring that we have
this vibrant planet for future
generations so i think now we can get
that done well said jeff and uh what is
next for you what will be the next
chapter in that story you're telling
helping to tell
well um i have a series on nacho wild
that i'm very proud of it's the first
series that i'm not in
it's a series that i created with my
partner patrick so we produced this show
for nachi wild called alaska animal
rescue and i'm launching two new series
um one of them is with a i can't mention
it specifically but one of our greatest
north american conservation
organizations and it's a series for a
big network where we travel around the
country to look what people are doing in
their backyards to save our planet
that's awesome jeff i can't wait to that
series and then a big international
series about kind of this is our last
chance to do it with the last generation
so those are the big big things on the
plate and i imagine everyone can find
all of this information on your um you
have instagram jeffcorwin on instagram
or twitter
yeah you can find me uh um i'm just
getting into the instagram thing i came
right after the emojis oh i'll follow
you i'm gonna follow it yeah it's wild
corwin
wild corwin
twitter and wild corwin facebook thank
you so much chef
enjoy the rest of the day enjoy the
beauty all right thanks justin
[Music]
so
so uh
so that happened i just love people that
that accent and his is very his i'm
surprised you didn't mention that to him
oh i almost yeah he almost got me yeah
you almost got me
yeah because his has like a maritime
hint like it's like a little
in the sub genre of boston accents isn't
there like a sort of a more maritime one
yeah it's like you could tell he fishes
yeah when you brought up his accent very
early on in fact before you brought up
his work
i there's a part of me that thought
what if he just talks to him the whole
time about his accent
like his boston pets with me the whole
time
i had like a moment of panic because you
like launched into that it's the first
thing i hear and like you kept echoing
certain words when when you enjoyed them
when you first meet somebody i never met
him before when you first meet somebody
that's uh
that's something that's easier to talk
about yeah i get why maggie loves him
yeah me too or maybe is in love with him
he has you know it's funny because i
hadn't been watching those shows
and so i i before we i did the podcast i
watched some and i right away i was like
oh
he's uh yeah he's like adorable he's
adorable
yeah yes yeah
yeah but also like super laid back and
it's a weird combination of like he's a
total package yes i like his uh dynamic
with his wife too i like how they're
like playful and like giving each other
yeah how about that when he like when
they called her up from when he was in
belize and that's right that's a crazy
crazy story i know that he was wearing
divas
i thought i was an outdoorsy kid and
like adventure i'd catch frost frogs and
snakes and stuff and when he said that
he told that story about the garter
snake i
had had a neighbor done that to my
garter snake who knows what would happen
you know what's funny about you i just
realized this i think had it not been
for
your attraction to the opposite sex
you might have stayed on that path
honestly think about it maybe that's
when you started acting
when you wanted to be around the pretty
girls yeah yeah or any girls
yeah yeah
yeah they're not as many pretty girls in
herpetology no but that's what derailed
you from before that yeah all you really
seemed to care about i mean you liked uh
claymation and drawing and that yeah i
liked art but i loved i remember you
loving
frogs and turtles it was my like life's
passion yeah i like how you kept trying
to show off your knowledge about i did i
knew you were
snakes and at one point he was like and
then there's the hellbender you're like
hellbender i said at the same time i
knew i was proud of myself and i
something occurred to me i knew you were
going to bring this yeah but he also
wasn't he didn't give it to you no he
was non-plus yeah he wasn't like whoa
that's actually really impressive that
you know that i had to be at a certain
point you were like hey pretty good
right oh i know i know and here
something occurred to me that um
i have a you know how like know-it-alls
you know kid it's usually like kids but
i've seen it in adults too some people
don't grow out of it where they're like
it's like playing jeopardy with somebody
you're like i knew that like i they brag
about the stuff they know i realized
that i kind of have that instinct
with uh
when it comes to
this kind of stuff yeah but you also as
proud of it like him you respect him and
you want i wanted him to know that
you're down cool yep
yep but that's anyone who would have
that interest the same way i wanted
mcconaughey to know that like hey i
lived in austin everywhere i like weird
it's actually very similar yeah kind of
but i don't think it's a bad thing i
think it's your attempt to i know this
is a positive spin on it this is your
attempt to relate to the guest yeah to
connect yeah that's what people do the
negative spin i guess would be like i'm
insecure and i just need him to like me
right i need validation well maybe it's
somewhere in the middle
yeah but i did want to impress him for
whatever i mean who knows why but uh i
like your positive spin you did this the
stephen bruhl
uh
oh that was for you when he goes yeah he
sat around it down he said the orvis fly
fishing school is on that river and you
go i know i know that so for those of
you who don't know um i that's for
whoever listens to uh check it out with
dr steve bruhl
uh john c riley plays this character who
um doesn't really know anything and
and whenever an expert says something
like very definitively like you know i
if you know you know when people say
that i'm instagram but this is one of
those that's true i do know you know but
it's so it's a fun thing to say when
somebody says something kind of obscure
and but in like a matter of fact exactly
when they're like yeah like that's the
perfect thing
you're like you need to well you need to
take uh three separate uh puddle jumpers
to make it to the main island in
papua new guinea i know i know
yeah uh good news about your turtles how
you didn't um
do anything really harmful and and they
might be able to reassimilate back into
the wild i was relieved however you
didn't tell him that you also have two
snapping turtles mixed in with your six
painted turtles i love you didn't
mention that well but i looked it up i
did look it up and those are the only
two species that you can keep in
captivity at least together yeah uh yeah
people have kept them together and they
say at a certain age you have to
separate them because
i'm seeing it already the snapping
turtles are growing uh exponentially
bigger than the painted turtles but so
far they're yeah i mean it's funny to
watch them because like these painted
turtles will step if you've never seen a
snapping turtle up close they're really
um
they're i think they're incredible
looking but they're they're starting to
snap too oh yeah at me when i'm taking
them out their feet together
yes these two little ladies
and you can hear their jaws clamp shut
they have really power i mean when they
get older there's a species called the
alligator snapping journal did he talk
about that i don't think that's it's um
they've been around since the dinosaurs
thought virtually unchanged uh for
hundreds of millions of years which is
another cool thing about reptiles but uh
they and there's a whole conservation
effort about these alligators have
materials but they have such powerful
bite they can cut they can take off uh a
foot
they can like kill somebody
these things they're not not the ones
you have no no no they live down what
can they what can your guys take
bite off oh i'm sure you've seen their
grown remember when we uh ran into that
snapping turtle on the road that's the
same kind that's the same kind that big
and it's a female so these things are
gonna get that big yeah yeah and it's
funny that they're snapping at me
because it's like there's a part of you
i'm sure parents
this must be so relatable to some not
relatable not because the turtle owners
but like anyone who has uh kids
kids just like being
shitty to you or like you know pooping
on yours it's like what are you doing
i'm i'm taking care of you just like
that with your turtles only they're
biting um i
when he said he had um he went to gnome
alaska i knew i would about my life
that you were going to say no way
sure enough you did
is there a real groaner
is that a dad joke that must be a dad
joke that might be a grandpa joke the uh
when you asked him who would play him in
the biopic i realized it's our first
guest whose biopic would be really
exciting yeah as a movie yeah who would
play i'm not thinking who would play
jeff corwin uh like someone like matt
damon isn't he a little mad oh he is oh
my god that's or greg kinnear
um
correct in your little not like built
as much you know there's something
that's jeff corwin's like yeah he's
sturdy yeah yeah yeah matt damon gets
great in here
no that's a good choice also
massachusetts he's he could do the
accent yeah maybe that's what i was
thinking of but also he's got like a
little n he's got that like
like little kind of face like little
cute like turned up situation uh very
very cool pragmatic
way of seeing the world and and the
afterlife
and uh he's just very present and yeah
he said life is gonna life is gonna do
what life is gonna do you know it's just
like this is just
take your shot and roll the dice and i i
i wish i had more of that mentality
because i'm i i envy it i think it's i
think it's the right way to do it but i
wonder if he has uh cultivated that
through a life of
being around a lot of life and life and
death and having i wonder if that gives
you i wonder if that just naturally
instills in you a more pragmatic view
maybe
he also had a remarkably
cheery disposition i thought for someone
who
is so aware of how bleak things are
i know in terms of yeah you know this
being the last he talked about us being
the last
species you know the last um generation
well that's like save the planet and
yeah there's a mass extinction going on
and he knows so in such detail
all the problems that exist and yet and
he cares so much about it and all the
species that we're losing it's hopeful
and positive i think that's pretty
remarkable it is that that he wouldn't
be just like
mired in a like cloud of
hopelessness that it wouldn't just be
like oh my god
but also i
he does so many things and he seems like
such a a doer and he he's he's so
excited by the world and all that that
it has to offer that i'm surprised he
he is so ambivalent about death that
he's not more
that because he cherishes life and he
lives it to such an extent that i'm
surprised he's not more um
cautious about
the potential for dying
i mean he's still handling snakes and
stuff and he never once said like oh i
you know i don't do that anymore because
i
i value or maybe because he sees how
fragile life is and he sees
how um
entire species go away
he doesn't place as much value on his
own life yeah
as others might you know and he sees
himself more as just one more creature
in a
world of so many creatures you know
that's um he places less importance on
his own existence almost yeah that's a
mindset that i
have when i'm whenever i'm watching
those shows i i feel a little bit more
like that like it diminishes my own
importance in the universe it's like
what's the opposite of solipsistic yes
it's like that's what he is he is he's
just part of this natural world yeah
what is the opposite of that um a
god it's like you've got such
perspective that you are no longer
considering your life not that it's not
valuable but it doesn't
have this part of this this system yeah
you're just
a piece of it you're a cog sometimes
yeah
but it must make it it's like to your
point it must make the idea of death uh
not quite as as monumental
you know because you're when you're when
you are solipsistic and you are the
center of the world then god that the
idea of the world as you know it just
ending it's almost like the world's
actually it is right and sometimes and
i've vacillate between those two
mindsets i'm usually closer to the
solipsistic one which is like oh my god
when when i end how can the world carry
on i know it sounds crazy no i know i i
like sometimes the same way you don't
both have to be solipsistic
uh let's read a letter
i knew it i knew wow there
i always suspected
okay
this is from nikki
uh niki
subject canadian shorty ah
hi justin and christian i'm a
stay-at-home mom of two teens and one
young adult
huh i discovered your podcast on
november 30th of the dreaded repetitive
year
as of today i have caught up on all
episodes it helps to well it helps to
have something to listen to as my kids
are remote learning during all this
chaos
thank you for being my break from the
craziness which is my household
i'm laughing at all your canadian
references
not everyone in
not everyone in canada pronounces a boat
as a boot okay that's probably true
that's definitely true
but or maybe she just doesn't hear it
maybe it's uh not to american explain to
her but maybe she doesn't
her ear is not a tune as a
i've heard uh varying degrees of varying
degrees but i think there's always some
about
i think there's always even like i've
been listening to norm mcdonald and well
you know he doesn't have a boat he has a
slight can a very slight accident but
but she
you know now that i think about i've
heard canadians not say boot okay sorry
not everyone in canada pronounces about
as a boat
every province has their own way of
saying things
yeah i bet um
as a prairie girl i say about huh
i have a girlfriend from the maritimes
newfoundland that says a boot
is it newfoundland newfoundland i just
said newfoundland new york newfoundland
newfoundland yeah i mispronounced it
does anyone say new what did i say uh
newfoundland okay
uh
newfoundland right that's what i say um
we should ask uh nikki nikki's
girlfriend i am uh okay back to nicki i
am a real life
what is that
i earned the nickname because most of my
friends could never pronounce my maiden
name right my maiden name is croaker oh
oh no pronounced quaker weird it's
spelled k-r-o-e-k-e-r
i would say croaker too yeah craker
quaker they would call me croaker yeah i
get it they're for froggy ah i've been
proudly called that for 30 years froggy
it's a cool nickname it is froggy
justin you had a a boat of poison ivy in
spring
justin you i wish you must have done
that on purpose do you think she said
about of it no you had a bout of poison
ivy in spring you know why how else is
she just tempting me to say a boot is
she just maybe but you did you famously
had poison ivy this spring i did but
it's a funny way of saying it after
talking about a boot and about justin
you had a boat about of poison ivy in
spring
i'm a chronic poison ivy sufferer whoa i
don't know you have chronic poison i
mean i've had it every summer for 35
years
what i've been told i'm allergic to it i
have a standing prescription at the
local pharmacy for medication if i ever
get it i've learned i wonder what
medication why doesn't she just avoid
the uh what does she maybe that's the
problem
just get it right does it come on when
even if you don't touch it that's if
it's wonderful that's what it sounded
like she said chronic i've learned a few
tricks in those years one when washing
when washing you soap with tea tree oil
in it it dries out the poison ivy huh
that's good to know two to soothe the
itch
it's tough to have the word two right
after the number two two to soothe the
itch soothe that's also hard soothes and
the in a row
two this is tough four words to say in a
row she's [ __ ] with you because she
does like how you make fun of her accent
yeah
two to soothe the itch use lavender oil
and lotion ooh lotion
for the lotion this too will help dry it
out but it will also soothe the skin and
three take nettle capsules when you have
poison ivy it helps draw the infection
oh good advice yeah thank you nikki uh
would you rather okay
god i'm so curious if she has if she
just comes up every year if it's in her
system that's what it sounds like
otherwise maybe stay away from poison
ivy um would you rather would you rather
have to say everything that comes to
your mind immediately
or
this is a good one or never be able to
speak again
yes this is for the rest of your life
that is a good one
see for me i what's that movie that it's
like liar line
uh yes man not speaking ever again it's
that one's a non a non-starter for me i
it would be really tough for me to pick
that option no matter what the option
other option was and
saying what comes to your mind would be
difficult and annoying but like you
would have to become different but it's
also i don't always
know
like the words to assign
things that are in my head exactly yeah
but it but it would force you to do that
number one and number two if you have to
say everything out loud can't you just
go and mutter it to yourself in a corner
you don't have to present it to
whoever's around i'm sure you could say
it
more quietly you know what else you'd
have to do
you'd have to
get into some sort of um
zen meditation thing where you can like
turn your brain off you have to be
disciplined you have to be disciplined
with your thoughts yeah and i that by
the way that's not a bad thing to be
anyway i would definitely pick that
because you're not talking even not
talking for a week would be pretty
torturous me too and also think about
this i'm now considering because i would
i have to take that option so now i'm
trying to make the most of it the best
of it um if you're saying everything
that pops most of the things that pop
into my mind are really banal
you know they're really like right
they're just like oh this thing's bright
this light is bright and oh my seltzer
water's getting less cold can you say it
quietly
yeah you'd have to but i'm saying uh
like in terms of the um looking at that
one positively that people would stop
really paying attention to what you were
saying
you would still be really annoying to be
around of course you would be very
annoying to be around but um
the things that would slip out that were
maybe maybe you didn't want to say out
loud or like that might be offensive or
yeah um
get you know you would just have to like
you said become very disciplined
at training
your thoughts you know you'd have to get
control of your thoughts somehow it'd be
very in a way that i don't have right
now it'd be very hard because when i
meet i mean imagine meeting somebody and
then i would just start describing how i
felt about their face but i would force
myself not to think that way you know
what i mean you'd have to change how you
think exactly but certain things yeah i
mean you'd have to
you'd have to i'm thinking about it
i'm going to be thinking about it
actually every that's an interesting one
to think about
yeah giving voice to all of your
thoughts interesting i feel like you're
doing that right now i am
you're you're working through your
thoughts right but my thoughts are so
innocuous that for the most part they're
just like seeing things and but those
aren't thoughts those aren't thoughts
yeah
there's a difference between a right and
a
sensation
yeah like a sense like i see
that but you weren't thinking about that
i see that window right now yeah i
wasn't thinking about it i'm just
seeing it so you wouldn't have to say
that out loud so now i'm saying the
things out loud that i'm thinking of
right it's not so bad no it's not great
it's like yeah
i think a lot of people beg to differ
speak for yourself um
okay well that's a really interesting
nikki thank you
and then she says uh personally i
already say pretty much everything that
comes to my mind that already so it
wouldn't be much different than now yeah
i mean it definitely wouldn't be
different than now now
much love from canada nikki well much
love back and uh and now i want to know
she calls herself a prairie girl what
are the prairie countries uh is that
like provinces province oh god alberta
saskatchewan manitoba manitoba sorry
manitoba manitoba i wonder what their
she says their each province is
different now i want to know
how different how they are different um
anyway thanks and uh that was so nice
that's really interesting it's nice to
get one that um makes makes you think a
little bit more than yeah that's a good
one yeah um and speaking of yeah and
good tips for your um
inevitable next bout with oh yeah poison
ivy i'm sure i'll get it i i tried to i
did a little preventative measure the
other week i clipped a bunch of what i
thought was poison ivy before um
you know while while the leaves were off
and everything are you doing that thing
now or you say everything that comes now
i'm thinking well now i'm also thinking
about like other thoughts i have that i
just had a thought like oh that's a
boring thing to say and who cares well
that's okay to say that's funny when you
say that it's okay all right
uh okay thanks nikki thanks nikki and
thanks jeff corwin for gracing us with
your presence with your um vast
expertise yeah i wonder what jeff corwin
would be like to make out with
see yeah why oh you're doing the thing
again
just kidding um i wish i wasn't thinking
about you and jeff coron making out yeah
well i wish i wasn't thinking about what
maggie's going to think about when she
hears me talking about jeff gordon uh in
a in a romantic way maybe we'll have to
pick the non-talking option
so far i think we do
uh life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by
one christian long as well as produced
by one megan monaco and one senior
producer would be michelle
audio engineer on this particular one is
sergio enriquez speaking of producers
the executive kinds are marshall louis
and hernan lopez
for a company that someone at some point
named wandery
[Music]
are you joking are you is this a joke
you think
i think
i think
it bear real bears don't eat honey or
they would like any other animal but i
don't think they like specifically more
than others
you could google do bears like honey
more than other mammals
i i just don't i don't know why so many
cartoon bears would be into honey if
it's not based on a real thing in life
but why maybe it's just based on their
cartoons that like that that became a
popular what
you think the originator of bears only
time was
the card soon
so that
and it was so good and likable like um
what was that so why was there just a
peanut butter or something like why
honey why not whoever thought ice cream
why not ice cream could have been
that would have gone up [ __ ] that
would never catch on very much
so why not make up something else
accessible why why is it could have
apples could have
it could have no because they have no
opposable thumbs imagine a bear getting
an apple it must be so easy now to scoop
out am i just picturing cartoons yes
scooping out from like and like they
don't
i know i've never seen a real bear do
that but
you